the situation
of the metapolitical situation of these
davos-like people these Geniuses these
these self-appointed benevolent betters
who are going to take all our rights and
sovereignty and traditions away and
they're going to tell us exactly how to
live
there there are so Brazen in in their
approach to things and their vision is
so so hideous
that you you are seeing even the pope
speak out against it
and I I say this
with some surprise because or or at
least recognizing the surprise that many
of you might feel when you hear this
because Pope Francis has a reputation of
being
a little bit more on the liberal side
a little bit confusing in some of his
statements a little bit soft maybe on
the Chinese government a little bit more
favorable toward these liberal
globalists around the world
that is at least the public perception
and I think that the public has reason
to understand those things but as I have
tried to point out time and time again
Pope Francis is not just the Communist
caricature that you read about in the
newspapers people try to portray Pope
Francis as pro-lgbt agenda they forget
that he said when he was Cardinal Buenos
Aires that gay marriage quote unquote is
not merely a political campaign but
rather quote imagination of the Father
of Lies who seeks to deceive and confuse
the children of God and when he was
asked by specifically by the German
Bishops but by a lot of the libs within
the Catholic Church to permit blessing
Ceremonies for gay marriage and that
sort of thing Pope Francis said that the
Vatican cannot bless sin and so he's
been very clear he sounds extremely
right-wing and based on an issue such as
that on abortion some people might
suspect because
Pope Francis sounds kind of liberal
sometimes
that in our
secular world if you don't understand
the history and the inertia in the
authority of the church
you might expect Pope Francis to be
pro-abortion he's not he said that if
you go and get an abortion it's like
hiring a Hitman okay you can't be any
clearer than that and even on this issue
of the big Libs The the globalist type
people who want to bring us zip off
Industrial Revolution as the world
economic Forum calls it that this this
complete upending of society where
artificial intelligence and computers
are basically going to run the show and
we're going to seed all of our political
rights and traditions to to the
computers basically to technology under
the control of an increasingly
globalized Elite Pope Francis says hey
watch out there are strict limits here
that you cannot pass a really important
statement he just made to the
Renaissance conference in Rome the ren
asons with the a i capitalized in it is
a
a Catholic uh
campaign focused on the ethics of
artificial intelligence and Pope Francis
said we are all aware of how artificial
intelligence is increasingly present in
every aspect of daily life both personal
and social it affects the way we
understand the world and ourselves it's
really important too because
you know we're all afraid of being
turned into cyborgs but in many ways we
already are cyborgs when you are walking
around
how often are you not looking at your
phone when you are just walking in your
day-to-day life or at the office or in
school or wherever how often do you not
have your phone on you I try to not have
my phone on me and people get angry at
me they say I just texted you why didn't
you text me because I never text anybody
back well I I just called you where I
saw it under my phone on me what do you
mean well this if your phone is always
on you and you're always plugged into it
then you are in a way of sort of a
cyborg and it affects the way that you
view even who you are but Francis goes
on he says innovation in this field
means that these tools are increasingly
decisive in human activity and even
compelling in human decision making now
let's put a pause there he's saying it's
not the technology does not merely
facilitate the decisions that you want
to make the technology increasingly
pushes you toward the decisions that it
wants you to make that's what social
media algorithms are that's what when
you go shopping on Amazon that's what
Amazon is doing it's pushing you toward
purchasing certain products the the tick
tock and the Instagram and the who knows
what of it all
are pushing you toward consuming certain
images which is pushing you toward
cultivating certain desires which is
pushing you even further toward the ends
that it has in store for you
and it's not just the computer that has
these ends in store it's the people
running the computers and so
so rather than just seat our lives away
to the people who make the algorithms
and run the computers that motivate our
decisions but for instances
I encourage you
ethicists on AI to continue in your
Endeavor I am pleased to know that you
also wish to involve the other great
world religions and men and women of
Good Will so that Al Gore ethics ethical
reflection on the use of algorithms will
be increasingly present not only in
public debate but also in the
development of Technical Solutions put a
pause there this is a really strange
statement to come from the pope where he
says I'm glad you're involving the other
great world religions hold on the claim
of the Catholic church is that the
Catholic church is the the divinely
instituted Church of Earth the spiritual
Israel the bride of Christ on earth and
the pope is the Vicar of Christ and so
this relativistic language of all the
other great world religions oh you know
we're all accessing the truth man and
you know we're all I grab the truth and
I I think that God is like a tree a big
tree trunk and I think that God is like
a fire hose and I think that God is like
a big wall and actually it turns out
when we all see how we're really
thinking of these things someday
we were all touching an elephant you
know and one person was touching the leg
and one person was touching the trunk
and one person was touching the side and
so we were all all the religions are
kind of getting at the same thing man
you know we're just no one has a
monopoly on the truth that's not a
Catholic idea okay the Catholic idea is
actually yes the church does have a
monopoly unreligious truth because God
has a monopoly on religious truth and
Christ on Earth instituted this this
church and and gave a special role to
the apostles and specifically to the
successor to Saint Peter and to the
successor of Saint Peter so Catholics in
particular are going to look at the
statement from Pope Francis and say wait
what's going on here come on and maybe
it's because Pope Francis is a big labor
or something but I I would prefer to
interpret this in a more charitable way
which is I think Pope Francis
is rightly observing that
the the immediate battle that we have to
fight right now against this
Leviathan that stands before us this
battle that we have to fight right now
against the increasingly technologically
powerful
atheist globalist secular Elite
means that we are going that the battle
lines are not going to be
the Catholics versus the Presbyterians
that's not the that's not maybe that's a
battle for another day I don't know arm
up you Presbyterian someday someday
we'll hash out that battle but that's
not what's going on right now the battle
is not even between the Christians and
the Muslims we've had those battles
called the Crusades battles not between
the Christians and the Jews the battle
is not that the battle right now
is between it's it's on a much lower
grounding actually it's it's sad that it
has to be on this really basic level but
it's between people who recognize that
there is a metaphysical reality that God
exists that the soul exists the world
economic Forum says the soul doesn't
exist you've all Harari who is the one
of the philosophers of the world
economic Forum he says the soul this is
fake news the resurrection of Jesus
Christ this is fake news It's Not Human
Rights it's fake news
and so the battle here is yeah if you
want to if you want to get anything done
we we need supporters here and so the
battle is between people who recognize
God exists humans are made in the image
of God
and we're not just we're not just stuff
and matter to be dragged Along by a
computer and an algorithm that's how I'm
choosing to interpret that and I think I
think if that is the correct
interpretation it certainly if if that
is what Pope Francis had in mind or
whether it isn't what Pope Francis had
in mind it certainly is
true of the situation nevertheless he
goes on he says indeed every person must
be able to enjoy a human and supportive
development without anyone being
excluded we must therefore be vigilant
and work to ensure that the
discriminatory use of these instruments
does not take root at the expense of the
most fragile and excluded let us always
remember that the way we treat the last
and least of our brothers and sisters
speaks of the value we place upon human
life we can take the example of Asylum
Seekers we can take the example of all
of the marginalized people who are
fragile and excluded let us remember
that uh that it is not acceptable that
the decision about someone's life and
future be entrusted to an algorithm and
this is really important
you are
you are seeing here
that the the real Line in the Sand is
humans must remain the stewards of
creation
we can't just delegate that away like
the Congress delegated away so many of
its powers to the alphabet agencies in
the executive branch we cannot just
delegate away our stewardship of the
creation to a computer
we cannot establish the domination of
Technology over the origin and Destiny
of human life this is one of the strong
arguments against in vitro fertilization
or increasingly you're hearing really
messed up stories there's one I wanted
to get to today we don't have time to do
it about the actress Anna Kendrick who
was lamenting her breakup she said I'm
I've had this boyfriend and we made
embryos together and then we broke up
okay well you made it means you had
children together
you you've got Souls on ice over there
and you say no I no longer care about my
children let them freeze forever or let
them be destroyed let them die or
whatever
one of the arguments against things like
in vitro fertilization yeah there are
many arguments but one of which is it
establishes the domination of Technology
over the origin and Destiny of human
life
it disrespects our
our own humanity and we as as people who
were made in the image and likeness of
God that is a huge threat there is
always a political battle between
between policies that will degrade human
beings or policies that will recognize
the Dignity of human beings what's
happening right now because of the the
means and opportunity afforded by
technological advancement and
globalization
we are at the precipice of a major
battle and it's not a battle over tax
cuts it's a battle over who controls us
it's a battle over what controls us it's
it's a battle over
what will human beings even be going
into the future you've got to become a
member of daily wire so head on over
daily wire.com
use code Knowles at checkout yeah two
months free
on all annual plans we will see you at
the member block
[Music]
thank you foreign